Narrator:
This is the Shark Tank,
where entrepreneurs
seek an investment
to start, grow, or save
their business.
The product has
so much potential.
Narrator: If the sharks
hear a great idea...
It's deal time.
Yes!
Narrator: ...they'll invest
their own money...
Oh, my God!
Narrator: ...and fight
each other for a deal.
The problem is --
Wait. I don't need your problem
-- bup, bup, bup, bup.
Stick to your basketball.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no.
Narrator: The entrepreneurs
must get the full amount
they're asking for...
I'm a hustler.
Narrator: ...or they'll walk
away with nothing.
Who cares?
Well, you care.
Barbara's very confused.
I just can't believe
why the other sharks
aren't all over this.
Because you have nothing!
Nothing!
Shut up, Kevin.
Narrator:
Who are the sharks?
They're self-made
business experts worth billions.
Kevin O'Leary is
a shrewd venture capitalist
who made his fortune
selling a children's
educational company
for over $4 billion.
Barbara Corcoran went from
waiting tables in Manhattan
to building the city's premiere
$2 billion real-estate empire.
Robert Herjavec, son of
an immigrant factory worker,
founded one of
the world's preeminent
cyber-security firms.
Lori Greiner, the queen of QVC,
holds over 100 patents
and has launched
more than 400 products,
grossing over a half a billion
dollars in sales.
And Mark Cuban,
esteemed billionaire tech mogul
and the outspoken owner
of the Dallas mavericks.
First into the tank is a product
that seeks to relieve an ailment
that 8 out of 10 people
suffer from.
♪♪
Hi, sharks, it's great
to meet you guys today.
My name is Katherine Krug,
and I'm the creator
of BetterBack.
Today I'm seeking
a $750,000 investment
for a 7.5% equity stake
in my company.
Wow.
So, sharks, check your posture
right now.
I'm especially looking
at you, Cuban.
Yeah, what can I say?
-[ Chuckles ]
It turns out that we sit for
over 9 hours every single day,
and because of the way
we're doing it,
hunched and rounded towards
our work and our technology,
it means 8 out of
every 10 people you know
will have back pain
in their lives.
My back pain started
over three years ago,
and I have spent so much time
and money
trying dozens of products
and therapies,
and I couldn't find anything
that just worked.
So I made BetterBack.
BetterBack allows you
to effortlessly sit
in perfect posture,
easing back pain and retraining
your body's default posture,
so when you stand or sit
without BetterBack,
your posture is greatly
improved.
It's lightweight and portable,
so you can throw it in your bag
and make every
single chair ergonomic.
BetterBack is just the start.
I'm on a mission to disrupt
the orthopedic aisle
and help people not just have
better backs,
but to live better.
So, sharks, who's got my back?
I want to try it on.
-Yes.
Great.
I've got samples for you guys.
Start with you guys here.
-This is Lori's?
-Yes. Thank you so much.
-And we do what he did?
O'Leary: How do --
Greiner: You put it over
your knees and then around --
and around your back?
That's exactly right.
I'll walk you guys through it.
So, you guys will start
by placing two feet
flat on the floor,
which is just great
ergonomics.
Next, you'll notice
the up arrow,
so that's the side
that goes up.
So, yeah, wrap the back pad
around your back...
Okay.
...and you'll wrap the kneepads
around your knees.
After you put it on
the first time,
it gets much easier and faster
to put it on.
The best thing to do is,
once the kneepads
are over your knee,
if it's loose enough,
you'll want to lean forward
and pull on the adjustable
straps while you sit up,
which should put you in
a really supportive position.
Katherine, it was
pretty intimidating,
putting it on or seeing it.
It seemed like it was
complicated -- what goes where?
Once it's on,
I have to tell you,
it's like
you can totally relax.
Katherine: Yay!
The ball of your back
is in perfect position.
I love it!
Who's this gentleman
sitting here?
He is my hunky model --
my fiancé!
-Ah.
-[ Chuckles ]
Congratulations.
-So, tell us how it started.
-Yeah.
So I was building
my last start up,
and I was working
the 14-hours-a day,
6-days-a-week grind,
and just the act of
rounding towards my laptop
for so many hours a day set off
terrible sciatica pain,
and I tried dozens
of products
and they all had some
really great components,
but nothing was
a full solution.
A buddy of mine was in
industrial design.
We came up with a prototype
that did help me sit
and relieve a lot of the pain
that I experienced.
So I launched my product
on Kickstarter in April.
I had a $12,500 funding goal.
I ended up selling 100 times
my funding goal.
I became the first solo woman
to break the million-dollar mark
on Kickstarter --
-Good for you.
-And I sold -- Thank you!
Whoo-hoo!
I sold $1.2 million worth
of BetterBacks
in just over a month.
-Wow.
Have you shipped
any of those?
Right now, I have 10,000 units
that have just left my factory,
another 10,000
that are leaving Monday,
and the remaining 10,000 units
are leaving at the end
of the month.
So your customer has not yet
tried the product.
Correct.
Katherine, why do you think
that many people bought it?
So in America alone,
this year,
50% of working Americans
will have back pain.
The numbers are staggering.
$50 billion is spent
on back pain every year,
just in the United States.
How much does it cost you
to make them?
My cost is $8.05 per unit.
And you were selling that --
And I was selling it for $49
on Kickstarter.
You've imputed a value
of $10 million on it.
Why?
So, $1.2 million in sales
in just over a month.
I have, from that,
$875,000 in the bank.
I think I can land $4.5 million
in online sales next year.
Let me stop you
with your online sales.
How will you generate
the traffic to --
It's one thing on Kickstarter,
something else when you're
another store living online,
trying to get the eyeballs in
to look at you.
Absolutely.
What's your plan for actually
making that happen?
Yeah, so, two different
divergent tracks.
One is to jump on Amazon US,
UK, Germany, and Canada.
So there you're getting
the natural eyeballs.
I have met an amazing --
No, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no. No.
I have a growth hacker
who has helped --
A what?
Basically an Amazon
growth hacker...
Right.
...who has learned
how you optimize page,
optimize pricing
in order to drive --
That's all fine and good,
and you can even get up
to search results if you get
people to search, right?
Yeah. Mm-hmm.
But that doesn't
necessarily translate
into a-a projectable number
of sales.
I think you're asking way, way,
way too much for your valuation
based on the sales
only on Kickstarter.
So, for that reason,
I'm out.
Oh, you're out all the way?
Barbara!
Okay.
Yeah, I'm out all the way,
but you are a great salesman.
The challenge
is the valuation.
Katherine: Mm.
So let's talk about that.
I would love to see what you
guys think is a fair valuation,
because I really want
you guys --
You can't value it,
though, right?
-What you've done --
-Well, I think you can value.
You can't, though, because
what you've done is --
Well, you can.
You can take a guess at it.
If I had to write a check
as an angel,
I would say, "Look,
it's a great start."
I mean, it's always
a bit of a leap.
Yeah, but see...
To me, it's a $3.5 million
to $5 million company.
Then the next question,
Katherine,
is what's your core
competency, right?
And what your core competency is
just what you've said it is.
Growth hacking,
organized, promoting,
taking something and
getting it to a point
where you can ship it.
Right?
Now all the things
you haven't done
is where it becomes
a real business.
I think I'm an entrepreneur.
Honestly, to my core,
I'm an entrepreneur.
Yes, you are.
Yes, you are. Right?
I can be pigeonholed
into these things for now.
Yes, you are.
Yes, you are,
but you just came out here
and pigeonholed yourself...
[ Sighs ]
...into BetterBack.
And so, for those reasons,
I'm out.
No! Don't go out!
No, I didn't hear it!
I didn't hear it.
I heard it.
Katherine, I got to go back
with my gut feel.
You have all of
the right answers.
Okay.
Um, I just don't see anywhere
close to the $10 million.
To me,
the business is worth...
$3.5 million, $5 million.
Because all the stuff that you
have to do hasn't been proven.
I mean, for $750,000,
which is a lot of money,
the equity is about 20%.
I mean, I look -- I see
the reaction on your face.
I mean, that's -- that's what
I would offer.
So you're effectively giving me
a 3x multiple
on my 1.5 months
of selling, yeah?
I'm betting on what you've
proven to me you're good at...
Mm-hmm.
...today and with
your background.
The unknown
is the risk factor.
That's why
I'm valuing it there.
Absolutely.
Katherine, give that
some serious thought.
Because you have to actually
go out and get the business.
So that valuation
is $3.75 million.
It's not unreasonable.
I'll make an offer,
but I'm actually looking at this
a little differently.
I'll do it for 25%,
'cause of the amount of work
I'm going to have to do
and the people that work --
So you're giving her
a worse offer.
It may be worse.
It may be better.
Well, my offer certainly looks
better now, doesn't it?
It does. Lori.
Guess what time it is,
Robert?
What time is it, Lori?
It's deal time.
Yes!
Narrator:
Two sharks are out.
Katherine has two offers on the
table for her posture corrector,
BetterBack, but Lori also
seems interested.
Guess what time it is,
Robert?
What time is it, Lori?
It's deal time.
Yes!
[ Laughter ]
See, here's the thing.
I don't always have the same
point of the view
as my fellow sharks.
Robert said you're a starter,
and, you see, I like that,
because I'm a closer.
And I have a product
that we launched on QVC.
Well, in a just a handful
of months,
we've done $5 million in sales.
Oh, my gosh!
Yeah.
You go, girl.
No lie. No lie.
That's awesome.
Wow.
And I think that this could work
very well with it.
This is a demonstrable product.
I love demonstrable products,
'cause I can show them on QVC
and my show.
I'm gonna make you an offer.
I'm gonna give you
the $750,000,
but I'm gonna be at 20%.
[ Laughs ]
There's always a "but".
Herjavec: Oh, my gosh.
So the guy whose offer
you rolled your eyes at --
-I know.
-Let me tell you why.
Let me tell you why.
Because we all know
America has back pain.
Mm-hmm.
The thing you don't know is
what America's going to think
of the product.
You really need
to get it out there...
Absolutely.
...and it has to be certain
that they like it.
I mean, you're lucky to have
the offers on the table,
because we all -- it's like
rolling the dice.
-Crap out...
-And this is your roll the dice.
If you believe she's gonna
generate $5 million in sales,
it's a bargain.
-Right. Right.
-Here's another --
here's another option for you,
because I just like
to keep things interesting
in the Shark Tank.
Katherine: Please.
[ Laughs ]
If you really are concerned
about dilution...
I am.
...'cause you seem to be,
I'm very creative,
so I'll help you here.
[ Laughs ]
I look at this and say, if you
hit 50% of your forecast...
Mm-hmm.
...you can afford to pay me back
the $750,000
in the next 18 months,
all right?
I will loan you the $750,000.
I think it's an extraordinarily
large amount of money,
but I can securitize it
against your sales.
I'm gonna charge you 7.5%
for it, for 24 months.
You can pay me back any time you
want in any amounts you want,
and I want 5% equity
when we close the deal.
Katherine,
I love when he does that.
You know why?
[ Laughing ] Why?
Because then I decide
to do it, too.
[ Laughs ]
Yep.
When you have no creativity,
you have to copy.
So I'm gonna give you
the $750,000 as a loan.
I'll give you three years
to pay it back,
also at 7.5% interest,
but I'm gonna ask for 8%
of the company.
Basically, Lori's saying
that she's gonna sell
$5 million worth,
which will easily,
if the margins are
anything legit, right...
Absolutely.
...pay back the loan she's given
to you and interest.
Absolutely.
You know, for 8% of the company,
do you want to,
you know, get $5 million more
in sales?
-Yes.
-Come to me.
Come to me.
-Yes.
Are you saying yes
to Lori?
My one question is,
would you do it for the 7.5%?
Half a point
should not matter.
It shouldn't.
-That's exactly right.
Don't walk in
thinking in your head,
"Oh, but I wanted
the half a point."
You are a half a handshake away
from $5 million.
All you need to do is be the
other part of the handshake.
Okay. I'm gonna phone my friend,
you guys.
Thank you so much.
-What?!
You got to be kidding me.
I'm gonna be right back.
-She gave you --
You don't know?
Do not take this away
from me.
-Never leave the Shark Tank.
-No guarantee.
-Katherine, this is
business 101.
-No guarantee.
-Somebody offered you
what you're asking --
-The good news is I'm coachable.
I'm coachable.
Lori, you got a deal!
-Oh, my gosh.
-Better idea.
Thank God.
Good.
Good, good.
I'm really excited.
Thank you.
Congrats.
-Let's go!
-Congratulations.
Come on!
Go, before Lori
changes her mind.
[ Laughter ]
I love you, Lori.
Yay!
We did it, we did it,
we did it.
I went with Lori's offer today
because Lori is the queen!
She's amazing!
What a badass businesswoman
as well as just human being.
I'm looking forward to getting
the mentorship and learning --
learning her chops.
Narrator:
Earlier this season,
Jess Edelstein and Sarah Ribner
struck a deal
with Barbara Corcoran
for their all-natural
deodorant PiperWai.
Would you be willing
to go down to 25%?
Yes, I will.
What?!
Deal.
Narrator: Let's see what
they're up to now.
♪♪
We knew we'd get some sales
after "Shark Tank",
but we had no idea what
we were actually in for.
When we first pitched,
we had $110,000 in sales
and we had been in business
for only a year and a half.
It's been 4 weeks and we've
reached $1.3 million in sales.
Because we have
so many sales,
we are back ordered
and we have about 50,000
orders to get out.
It's taking 4 to 6 weeks
for PiperWai to reach
our customers' doors.
This situation
is not indicative
of how we want to be
running our business.
Sarah and Jess,
how are you?
Hi!
All those customers
don't mean a thing
if they're disappointed.
If the PiperWai girls
can't deliver their product,
we're gonna lose our momentum
and we're gonna lose
our customers' loyalty.
The moment you were
on "Shark Tank",
you outgrew this co-packer.
You need a second co-packer,
two labelers.
You need two
of everything,
because you can't rely
on only one supplier.
It's not good business,
but at the same time,
let's keep your customer
totally informed
as to when the product
is coming.
Okay. Well,
let's get to work, right?
Yeah.
Corcoran: The marching orders
are very clear.
We have to get
a second co-packer
and never keep customers
waiting again.
Show me what this is
right here.
Jess:
Even with the challenges,
"Shark Tank" has been
an amazing experience
completely beyond
our wildest dreams,
and we've been
able to reach a market
that needed a healthy,
all-natural deodorant solution,
and we've both grown as
businesspeople in the process.
♪♪
I'm Brittney Scarlett.
And I'm her
brother Skyler.
We live in beautiful
Carmel, California.
11 months ago,
we started this business.
We were both dissatisfied
with our jobs at the time,
and we saw
a huge opportunity.
So we took a huge
leap of faith,
and we opened
this business in Carmel.
-Doing okay?
-Yep.
We have a cutting edge
spa therapy
aimed at reducing inflammation
in the body.
I looked into this and I saw
many professional athletes
are swearing
by the therapy.
I tried it with my sister,
and we both got hooked on it.
-How's business been going?
-Business is good.
Our family has made
great sacrifices
for us to open up
this business.
Our dad actually
sold his house
to help us finance
our equipment.
And I live in a barn
on my mom's property.
There's no hot water,
there's no cable,
and there's bats,
but it's a sacrifice
that I'm willing to make
for my company right now.
If we can sell the sharks
on this new therapy,
hopefully we can get America
to give it a shot, too.
♪♪
Hi, sharks, my name
is Skyler Scarlett.
And I am
Brittney Scarlett.
We're from Carmel Valley,
California,
and together,
we're known as...
BOTH: The ice siblings!
Our company is
Glacé Cryotherapy.
We are here today seeking
a $100,000 investment
for 15% equity
in our company.
Whole body cryotherapy is a
cutting-edge, cool technology...
literally.
It all begins when you step
inside our cryosauna.
Wow.
-Oh, man.
-It's cool looking.
For up to three minutes,
cool, dry air
is circulated
around your body
at up to 250 degrees
below zero.
Cryotherapy is for
reducing inflammation,
and when you reduce
inflammation,
you will notice
less aches and pains,
decreased muscle soreness,
and have an overall better
sense of wellbeing.
We can help people naturally
manage their pain,
reduce their needs
for medications
to the point that after
consistent cryotherapy sessions,
they feel like
a brand-new person.
And there are many
other benefits.
Endorphins and adrenaline
are released,
increasing your energy
and improving your mood.
There is a calorie burn,
and it's also good
for your skin,
as it increases collagen
production.
How much to freeze
Mark Cuban's head?
[ Laughter ]
Well, Robert,
we know you're a sports guy.
Would you be interested
in getting in here
and trying it out?
I'd love to try it.
Sure.
-All right. Awesome.
-We'd love to put you in here.
So what you're gonna do,
Robert,
is you're gonna go
right behind that.
There's a robe back there
for you,
so you're gonna take everything
except for your underwear...
You're gonna take off
all your clothes.
...and you're gonna put on socks
and gloves and shoes and a robe.
I can't --
No one's
gonna see you naked.
Don't worry.
I'll make sure nobody sees.
How long do you stay in there?
Up to three minutes.
We try to get people to go
at least two minutes,
but never longer
than three.
Well, good news they
didn't ask me, 'cause
I'm going commando.
[ Laughter ]
Skyler: Oh, awesome.
All right.
He's ready.
Corcoran:
Nice socks, Robert.
Robert,
looks like your mug shot.
Don't worry, no one
can see you in here, all right?
No one can see you
in here.
Does it get cold?
It's gonna get cold.
Yep.
Guess what, Robert.
You won't be having any more
children after this.
No.
Robert, the good news is,
as cold as you get in here,
the second you get out,
you're gonna immediately
heat up, all right?
You're going from negative
about 220 Fahrenheit
to room temperature.
Nothing is wet on you.
It's completely dry.
It's not that cold.
It's completely dry
and it's very tolerable.
-Very, very tolerable.
-How does it feel?
Oh, it's pretty cold now.
[ Laughter ]
You're doing great.
All right.
What is the ma--
What is the maximum level?
Chin up a little bit.
The maximum level is level 3.
That can get as cold
as about negative 280.
-Give him five.
-You want level five?
O'Leary:
Give him five.
Corcoran: Robert, are you
regretting that you're in there?
You gonna make me a deal
if I do level five?
Oh, my God!
All right.
You're gonna heat up
immediately.
It's just the cool, dry air,
so you're not getting wet.
Now we know how to pack him
and ship him. [ Laughs ]
Watch your step,
all right?
Whoa, Robert!
Watch your step. Now
I'm gonna take your skin
temp on your ankle, okay?
Okay.
So we have him
at 32 degrees.
So normally,
we're 88 to 94.
When they go in here, the magic
is dropping the skin temp,
and that's where all
the science happens.
[ Laughter ]
Are you still cold, Robert?
-It's freaking cold!
-I guarantee you.
Give it about five minutes,
he's gonna feel
really, really good.
He's gonna feel relaxed. He's
gonna feel really comfortable.
[ Laughter ]
He's just being dramatic
right now.
How does it not
burn your skin?
Three minutes.
So we never go past three.
That's the key.
Do I look younger?
How do you feel?
I feel great.
What happens?
You get in there.
It, uh, it starts
slowly,
and then it gets
really cold.
Yeah.
Like all of a sudden, it goes
from tolerable to -- boom!
So we get that --
we get that it's cold.
Yes.
Okay.
Is there a business?
Tell us
what's going on there.
We started 11 months ago
in Carmel.
We've done $140,000 in sales,
$115,000 in gross profit.
Did you have expenses, though,
of a rental space or a spa?
Our overhead
is really great.
It's about $3,200 a month.
We have our own office.
We call it
a cryotherapy spa,
and our main expense
is gonna be gas,
and that's really it.
There's a lot of places
like this.
When I was on
"Dancing With the Stars",
all the dancers went to this.
-Yeah.
The Mavericks started using this
five years ago.
What's the difference
between you and the place
down the street?
Skyler, what stops me in Boston
from just buying gas,
a thing like that,
and calling it
Mr. Wonderful's
Freeze-a-tron?
There's, honestly,
there's nothing from
stopping you to do that.
You can go buy a unit try to do
Mr. Wonderful's cryotherapy.
So what do you got?
So the question we're asking
you, then -- why are you here?
It's the experience that we feel
that we provide.
It's working well for you
in Carmel, right?
We want the investment for
another Glacé in San Francisco.
Yes.
That's what we want
the investment for.
One machine.
What is the cost of one machine?
It's $55,000.
-Wow.
-$55,000.
Skyler, I've got a question
for you. Help me with this.
If I give you $100,000 for 15%
of the business, okay?
But I can buy the unit
for $55,000...
That's true.
...hire two Brittney-Skyler
guys...
You can try to.
...and own the whole thing
myself!
Yeah.
And I'll keep 100%
of the company.
We -- We feel that we have
the best practice.
Come on.
You have nothing.
Brittney, here's the --
What does it cost to do this?
A single session
would be $65.
Oh, that's cheap.
But we mostly sell
monthly memberships
that are about $390.
So, $65...
-Right.
-And then how many times
do you have to go
to see a result?
Most people are coming
anywhere between one to five
times a week.
Skyler, it works.
Yes.
-You didn't invent the process.
-Let's give it it works.
So let's talk about
your business.
-Why is it --
-Oh, God. Don't go again.
My issue is not with the fact
that whether it works or not.
You're just a retail store.
You're no different than
any other retail store.
Yeah. I don't believe we're just
like everyone else.
Okay.
Really, our training is
completely different.
You know, I think
there's really an art
to putting people
in here.
You can't just
throw them in there,
push a button
and "All right."
We get multiple requests
to be a Glacé.
They know they can do this
on their own.
Your premise is that
you're so unique
in your ability to help people
use the technology
that I should give you $100,000
and only get 15% when I can buy
it myself for $55,000.
-Ay-yi-yi.
-I'm stuck there.
I'm stuck there, because you
have nothing! Nothing!
If you want to do
Mr. Wonderful's cryotherapy --
I'm out.
You -- you guys have
a fundamental problem,
but it's not
what Kevin says.
It's absolutely
what Kevin said.
There are a lot of successful
service businesses...
Yeah.
...where people who provide
better service succeed,
but there's only
two of you.
And so trying to open up
that second location --
you don't have
the people to do it,
yet you're coming,
asking for money from us
to do it without the people
to do it.
That's a big hurdle
to overcome.
I'm out.
All right.
Thank you.
Thanks for your time,
Mark.
You're welcome.
I don't have a problem
with the fact
that you didn't invent this.
Someone's gonna create a brand
around this.
My challenge is all you want to
do is open up one more store.
If this really is gonna be
a national coverage model,
the person who's gonna win
is the one who's gonna be
out there more.
You've got to come out
with a game plan,
and you didn't come out with
a good game plan for me today.
I'm out.
Sorry to hear that.
Thank you.
Robert,
thank you for your time.
I think
it's really interesting.
I'm fascinated
by the science of it.
This is a great business for
you, but I think, at this point,
not investable for me,
so I'm out.
Thank you.
Thanks, Lori.
Barbara's left.
I just can't believe
why the other sharks
aren't all over this.
The magic sauce in this
is you make money
from the get-go.
Nothing is more appealing
to a franchisee
than making a killing fast.
Than make immediate money.
Boom.
That's your number-one question,
and you've already
demonstrated that.
Barbara, you would kill it
with these guys.
The problem is
they're gonna be --
I don't need your problem --
bup, bup, bup, bup.
I'm just telling you.
Thank you very much,
Mark Cuban.
Stick to your basketball.
[ Laughs ]
This is my space here.
-[ Laughs ]
-Okay.
I will definitely build this
to a million-dollar business
in sales within the first year,
because I know exactly
how to do it, all right?
So I'm gonna give you
the $100,000 for 30%.
If you don't take that,
you should freeze yourselves.
You're not telling secrets,
are you?
All right, Barbara.
We got a deal.
This is a no-brainer.
You're our girl.
You know what?
You fit in with my family.
You're the good guys.
-Hey, I love you.
-I love you back.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Thank you all.
Good luck, guys.
Nice to meet you.
-Oh, my God.
-Whoo!
That's unbelievable.
That's the American dream
right there.
Well, Barbara, you've proved us
wrong in the past.
-That's so ridiculous.
-You know what's wrong with you?
You give no value
to the entrepreneur.
These kids are golden.
Be one
with the nothingness.
Be one.
Embrace it.
Narrator:
Next into the tank
is a high-tech security device.
♪♪
Hello, sharks.
My name is Mohamed Mohamed.
No, I didn't stutter,
and yes, I love it.
I'm from Oakland, California,
and I'm the founder and CEO
of LINKA.
I'm seeking $250,000 in exchange
for 10% equity of my company.
When I've had a long day
at work,
I can at least leave
with a smile on my face
knowing I get to dodge traffic
by riding my bike home.
I get some exercise in
and even relieve some stress
while I'm at it,
but nothing would wipe that
smile off my face quicker
than coming outside to realize
my bike had been stolen.
This is the story of 1 million
Americans each year.
I was fed up with bike theft.
I knew I had to do something
about it,
and that's why I'm so excited
to introduce to you LINKA,
the world's smartest
bike lock.
It stays there, so you're always
ready to lock up.
No keys, no bags.
When you're ready to lock,
simply tap a button
and a hardened steel ring
slides into place,
making it impossible
to ride away.
And when you're ready to go,
LINKA will recognize you
as you approach
and automatically unlock.
LINKA is not just
smart hardware,
but our app will even
keep you posted
on your LINKA's battery life
and keep you up to date
on the history
of bike theft
in your neighborhood.
It will even recommend
safer places to park
and advise how to get there.
Sharks, more than two bikes are
stolen every minute in the US,
and this epidemic continues
to get worse and worse
the more and more cycles
hit the streets.
The need is there,
LINKA has the answer.
So who's ready to lock in
a deal with LINKA
and help us all lock smarter,
not harder?
What's to stop someone
from picking up your bike
and putting it in their car?
Well, that's a good question.
Why don't you come try it
for yourself?
See if I can pick it up?
[ Imitates buzzer ]
-Well, maybe come bring
the muscles.
Let me try.
Bring the muscles and just try
to lift this guy up right here.
-So that's a great question.
-Great question.
So I come up to it,
the steel thing goes in.
Mm-hmm.
Right?
Just pick it up.
You're trying to steal it.
Right.
Greiner: There he goes.
[ Alarm beeps ]
Yeah, well, you got to do that
with a 30-pound bike.
Close the doors!
You got to do that with
a 30-pound bike on your arm,
and at the same time,
you receive a tamper alert.
The user receives a tamper alert
on their phone,
letting them know that somebody
just tried to steal their bike.
So how does it stop the bike?
It stops the wheel from going?
-Right.
-You can't cut that off?
-Correct.
The proximity of where
the lock is mounted
makes it very difficult
for anybody to access
with bolt cutters --
Herjavec:
Oh, it's a tamper warning.
Yeah.
There's a reason people
chain their bike
to something hard
is so nobody can pick it up.
That's totally fair.
Like, the alarm goes off --
who cares?
Yeah, well, you care.
You're the one who is receiving
the alarm.
No, the crook cares because
you're carrying something
that everybody's gonna hear,
and on top of that, you still
got to get that thing off
in order for it
to have any value.
I don't know. I think you're
still gonna need a hard chain
to put something physical
to it.
Greiner: Is there --
I was gonna say, is there --
That's why we have a mounted
add-on noose chain.
There is.
So you can pick the
option with the chain
or without the chain.
-Where?
-It's right here.
It's mounted
onto the frame.
You can actually take this,
grab the front wheel
and the back wheel --
directly hooked on.
Okay, so, see, that works.
How much is it?
$129 MSRP.
-And what's it cost you?
-$45.
And if you add on the chain,
I'm into it for not $139,
but how much?
Uh, $159.
$159.
And how many have you sold,
Mohamed?
We launched a Kickstarter
campaign back in May.
and we actually did five times
our desired goal.
We hit about $130,000.
What are your sales
since then?
Sales since then --
about $40,000.
What is your background?
My background -- actually,
I didn't go a top-tier school
or an Ivy League school.
I went to The City College
of New York.
That's a better school than most
of those schools.
Thank you.
And I had the opportunity
to finish my mechanical
engineering degree there.
-Hey.
-And shortly after,
I started working for Toyota
as a manufacturing engineer,
so my background is heavily
in manufacturing and quality.
I also want to say something
about where I come from
and what makes me here --
what helps me come here.
Good for you.
Want to hear it.
I -- my parents immigrated
to this country
to help make my brother's life
and I a lot better.
And they sacrificed --
Where are you
from originally?
Egypt.
So they immigrated here
and they wanted to make
our lives better,
and they wanted
to help us succeed,
and they sacrificed
so much.
They left their family
and they left everything
they knew
to bring us here.
And I can't repay
them enough,
so I'm doing everything I can
every single day.
So go back to -- it's on there.
I'm coming out.
How does it open?
It automatically unlocks as it
recognizes your proximity
through BTLE --
Bluetooth low energy.
Corcoran: Mohamed,
I'm your perfect customer.
I ride a bike every single
morning of my life,
but when I park my bike,
there's something psychological
when I put that chain
around a post.
-Right.
-It makes me feel good.
When you don't have anything
that looks like a deterrent
to a thief in a big city
like New York,
I think it almost says,
"Come and get it."
I mean, that's a gentle alarm,
and I don't think it's enough
of a deterrent
to really have a practical
application,
and so for that reason,
I'm out.
I'm with Barbara
on this one.
I mean, I think,
in larger cities,
you're looking
for a deterrent.
You're looking for a heavy chain
that a guy walks by
and that's what stops it
from being stolen.
It's a quick thing.
So I will say, we're going
to Amsterdam on Tuesday.
This trip to Amsterdam,
we already have 45 meetings
lined up
with distributors, retailers,
biking manufacturers.
Why Amsterdam?
'Cause that's the capital
of the bike world.
Amsterdam has
a one-to-one ratio
between bikes and citizens.
I had my house broken into
many years ago.
I called in the police
and I said to them,
"What's the best alarm system
in the world that I can buy?"
You know what the police officer
said to me?
-Dog.
-"Buy a dog."
I said, "Why a dog?
How's a dog gonna prevent
a break-in?"
"It's gonna make the burglar
think twice,"
and I think a chain
is the same way.
That, to me, doesn't look like
a deterrent.
I'm sorry.
I'm out.
I'm sorry to hear that.
I was hoping, when Robert
was running off with it
and it was beeping,
that it would send out 240 volts
and hit him.
And, like,
then he'd drop the bike.
I'd rather hear it say,
"You stole my bike.
This guy's a crook."
"You stole my bike, now watch
this". [ Imitates buzzer ]
You know,
we see better mouse traps
all the time in the Shark Tank.
The challenge is this market
is already served
by many solutions,
and you've put a value on it
of $2.5 million.
You want $250,000 from me
for 10%,
computes to $2.5 million value.
I mean, it's just --
I'm not excited
about the product category,
mostly.
I find the valuation probably
about 50% too rich.
I'm out.
I'm sorry to hear that.
I mean, in terms of
the product itself,
the product has so much
potential.
I like the invention.
I think it's clever,
but I think that it has to be
a much louder alarm.
I'm a city girl.
I wouldn't have even heard that.
It would've been
white noise for me.
I wish you great luck,
but for me right now,
it's not investable.
I'm out.
Seriously,
we did our research.
We talked to 300
different customers
before we even started.
I don't think anybody here's
doubting your preparation,
the quality of the product,
the need for the product...
All excellent.
Yeah,
we all think it's clever.
The issue is the competition.
Right?
You're trying to build,
as someone said earlier,
a better mouse trap.
That -- that's brutally
competitive.
That's why you're having
to go to Amsterdam,
but if it was just
such an easy sale
and just a blow-away
opportunity,
you'd have
your hands full here.
And so, for those reasons,
I'm out.
I'm sorry to hear that.
-Good luck to you.
-Good luck, Mohamed.
Good luck, Mohamed.
♪♪
It is disappointing to walk out
of there empty-handed,
but I know deep down inside,
everything that I've worked hard
for, everything --
the blood, sweat, and tears
to get LINKA
to where it is today is not
gonna go unfulfilled
and LINKA's gonna keep going.
Narrator:
Next up is an entrepreneur
who's passionate about sharing
her love of tea with the world.
♪♪
Hello, sharks.
My name is Allison DeVane,
and I'm from Goodyear, Arizona.
Today I am seeking $50,000
in exchange for 10%
of my company, TEASPRESSA.
During my nine years in the
coffee and tea industry,
I've noticed that coffee lovers
really like coffee
because of the caffeine
and the rich texture,
however they're not huge fans
of the jitters and the crash.
I think that most people know
that tea is a healthier option,
but let's face it,
it's not as fun to drink.
That is, until now!
TEASPRESSA is concentrated
tea shots
made just like
gourmet coffee drinks.
It is not your ordinary tea bag
dunked into water,
because we make it in a way
that is just like espresso.
In fact, because of that,
it has a bold flavor,
rich consistency
just like coffee,
and just as much caffeine,
except without the jitters
and the crash.
We are revolutionizing
in a lucrative space
and need you our team
to help introduce this new
gourmet tea product, TEASPRESSA,
to the world.
And now it's tea time, sharks.
Today we have prepared for you
some of our most popular drinks.
-Ooh.
-Wow.
-Yeah, smoothies.
-Ooh-la-la.
-Yeah.
-Fancy.
So we have the Cucumber
Green Tea Lemonade.
-Thank you.
-This is a Black Rose Latte.
-This is really good.
-That's nice.
I'm glad you like it.
Has a florally
kind of taste.
And this is
the Black Vanilla Latte.
And then this is probably
our most creative drink,
the London Fog.
It's our earl gray with vanilla
and a splash of lavender.
Thank you.
And this is our most wildly
popular decaffeinated tea.
It has caramel in it.
-Cool.
Wow, like a dessert.
Allison, is the business
a retail store?
Like, what -- what is it?
Um, the business
is the tea shots itself.
I actually have a patent pending
on the process.
Show us the package.
Greiner: What does somebody
buy from you?
Herjavec: Yeah.
So I have them right now --
they're available
at a store.
Thank you.
So this is what I buy.
This is your product.
I have that
and I also have it available
in a store in Phoenix.
How I started was I did
pop-up shops in Arizona,
and then I just decided
I was going to make this
my full-time job.
I'm like
"I'm gonna give it a go,
'cause I've always wanted
to start a business."
So I hustled every day,
I live with my parents --
it's cool -- and actually
had an opportunity
to be the exclusive tea provider
for a store in Phoenix,
and so they love the product
so much,
they're like, "Oh my goodness.
You're perfect.
Let's put it in there."
And since then I have made
about $26,000 in sales
in five months
just from the tea alone.
Allison, you got to tell me how
I'm turning this into a product.
Allison: Yes.
So I have to buy
that little pot?
Yes.
Okay.
So now I need that
and I need the pot.
Yes.
Then what happens?
So, um, you make it
in the pot,
and then what you make is
something similar to that,
but it's not quite
the experience
that you have at the store.
That's not your product,
though.
This --
this is my product.
-The tea pot is?
-Just this.
Cuban:
How do I buy this?
Online.
Okay, so I go
to your website.
-Yes.
-What do I pay for it?
That is $12.
Greiner:
And so, just so it's clear...
-Yes.
-...two different things.
-You're in a shop in Arizona.
-Yes. Yes.
-Which you partially own?
Is that what you said?
-And you are serving and making
different teas.
-Yes.
-And you are also now
selling online...
-Yes.
-...the tea bags and the pot.
What is your plan?
What are you seeing to do here?
I want to be the person known
that made tea cool.
I have the trademark pending
for TEASPRESSA itself.
I have the patent pending
for the process itself.
The -- The patent includes
the brewing --
So am I investing
in the machine?
The technology
for it, yes.
Oh, you're gonna make
a machine.
Mm-hmm.
O'Leary: And you're gonna sell
a machine also.
I thought you were
making these.
Okay, so, you know, I must say,
at this point...
-[ Laughing ] It's confusing.
-...Barbara's very confused.
You told us
this is the product,
then you told us you're telling
a technology,
then you told us
you're in retail,
then you told us you're
in a store making them,
then you told us
you're online.
Can you see
why we're confused?
It's been very aggressive.
I'm a hustler.
-I see.
-I started --
-No, I know.
-No, but can you -- can you --
But we're not sure what
you're hustling, Allison.
-Yeah.
-That's the problem.
O'Leary:
So far in this presentation,
it's like you came
into the Shark Tank...
-Yes.
...someone rolled in
a dish-washing machine,
threw you in it, and we're
hearing every third word
as you go rotating
through the cycle.
Greiner:
Here's what's confusing.
What is it that --
that you're selling?
Are you selling
that machine there,
or do you want to be selling
those things up there?
Well, the store that I
have is more so a proof
of concept. And --
A what c-- okay.
A proof of concept, that people
love your espresso shots.
Allison: Right. It's kind of
been a great creative outlet.
People -- I've ben having lots
of, um, different kinds
of press.
I just do large publications,
like, logos on latte art.
I do, like, pineapples
or crazy designs
to a lot of doors for press.
Allison, how does this equate
back to this product?
Okay, um...
There's a scene
in a famous movie
where a trap door opens
and you fall
into a real shark tank.
I think we're almost there
with you.
♪♪
Narrator:
All sharks are still in,
but they're confused
about the business model
of Allison's tea company,
TEASPRESSA.
O'Leary: There's a scene
in a famous movie
where a trap door opens
and you fall
into a real Shark Tank.
I think we're almost there
with you.
All right.
So give it a good shot.
Give it a good shot.
-Aw.
-Make me understand
why a $50,000 investment
with you is worth it.
Okay.
With the $50,000,
I plan on making my website
absolutely tailored to sell.
Sell, sell, sell,
and then to develop --
finish developing these,
'cause I know what I need,
I know how to make
one of these.
I feel like now there's been
a lot of, you know, like,
you see a lot of coffee shops
and even Starbucks
investing in new
tea inventions,
and so right now,
it seems to be the time,
especially with the health trend
going up,
where people are looking
for healthier alternatives,
and that's the reason
why I'm actually here...
Allison. Folks --
Go ahead.
...is because I-I do --
I do need guidance.
Corcoran:
Here's the thing.
The need for you to communicate
more clearly, I think,
is the, really, only thing
you're doing wrong here,
but anticipating what it would
be like in that partnership,
I would have to say
that I'm out.
Okay.
♪♪
I have no idea what you do,
and you've squandered
this opportunity.
I'm out.
All right.
Um...
I'm here to make
the next Starbucks of tea.
-Let me help, Allison.
Allison, look.
I...
Deep breath.
That's the hardest part
to be in,
particularly when you're
coming in with a vision
and you're trying to learn
as you go, right?
So just a deep breath.
You've got this big vision --
"I want to make tea
better than coffee
and have people just
as committed to tea
as they are to coffee."
You did a great job
of articulating that.
Right. Right.
The problem is
you just came too early.
Right? Because you're
learning business.
It's nearly impossible
to figure out a vision,
execute that vision,
and learn how to be
a businessperson
at the same time.
But what you haven't
conveyed yet
is that you understand
the business part of it.
I know my margins.
But you've got to know
more than that.
Look, while I think you've got
a great vision,
I've got to say the words:
I'm out.
Okay.
Herjavec: Allison, it's a
testament to your character
and your exuberance
and your excitement
that we're all still talking
to you.
Any other person that would come
out here with that presentation
would've lasted a couple
of minutes.
Excitement, though,
is not a focus.
At this stage, you need
singularity of focus.
I'm out.
Okay.
These taste great.
Every shark loved them.
Delicious.
But in business,
you have to crawl
and then you walk
and then you run.
Right.
So you just have to take
each step one by one.
And I think that if you do that,
you can make it.
Today you came in
a little too early,
and for that reason, I'm out,
but just focus and bite away
at each inch.
I mean, I promise --
I know that that came out
like word vomit.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you very much.
Don't look at this
as a failure.
No.
Look at it as a failure.
Shut up, Kevin.
Allison:
Honestly, to be here,
it was kind of intimidating
because I just started...
[ Voice breaking ]
but this is something
that I'm so extremely
passionate about, and I...
[ Sniffles ]
Greiner: That's the thing.
If you're so really passionate
about it,
you will make it happen.
You're young.
You have a lot of years
ahead of you.
-I know.
-Keep working at it.
Yeah, you don't know
where that's been.
[ Laughter ]
Good luck, Allison.
-Good luck.
-Good luck, Allison.
-Thank you.
-Bye.
♪♪
Allison: [ Voice breaking ]
That was really hard.
Probably one of the best
experiences,
but the hardest thing I've done,
for sure.
I feel like it really does hurt
right now,
but [sniffles] I know I can turn
this into motivation
to do better.